pas pour ces messieurs du clos bonsoir
monsieur fillion vote soit gérald bon
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver si
vous étiez donc depuis quatre ans
ministre de la famille la location
canadienne pour enfants c'est vous qui
l'avez mis en place qu'au va vous
accueillir ce nouveau mandat aujourd'hui
déjà avec un peu de nostalgie parce que
mon ancien texte extraordinaire comme ça
ni enfin développement social ce sont
des dossiers que j'avais déjà étudié
durant 25 ans comme professeur en
économie à l'université laval dont
spécialiste de questions de politique
publique et politique sociale donc
investissements dans les âmes dans les
enfants dans les familles dans les
années dans la classe moyenne mais
évidemment être responsable et président
du conseil du trésor c'est un immense
privilège une grande chance que j'ai
parce que ce soit appelle une agence
centrale
c'est une agence qui traite de tous les
dossiers avec tous les ministères qui va
me permettre d'être utile et actif le à
beaucoup d'égards et vous l'avez dit le
mot investissement elle restera dans la
famille dans le développement social
c'est ça vous allez faire comme
président du conseil du trésor on vous
demande de tenir les cordons de la
bourse aussi vous allez obligé de dire
non à partir de maintenant à
quelques-uns de vos collègues wave est
une question d'efficacité aussi
l'efficacité de dans les infrastructures
c'est pas seulement le montant qui est
important c'est aussi la manière par
laquelle ces infrastructures sont effect
sont investis sont améliorées
non quand je vais être là pour aider mes
collègues autour des terres du cabinet à
s'assurer que ce qu'on voit investir au
cours des prochaines années pour un
nouveau les gens mais aussi les
infrastructures soit fait avec le
maximum d'efficacité
le maximum aussi de collaboration avec
les autres niveaux de gouvernement parce
qu'on sait quand le régime fédéral les
politiques publiques sont les plus
efficaces lorsqu'elles se font en
collaboration avec tous les niveaux de
gouvernement
jusqu'à quel point ce sera difficile en
même temps vous me permettrez d'être un
peu ironique parce que vous vous êtes
fait élire en 2015 sur des déficits qui
ont été finalement beaucoup plus grands
prévu et vous prévoyez des déficits
encore plus grand dans les prochaines
années 27 milliards pour la première
année je vais vous allez dire non à des
collègues mais pas tant que ça
finalement
mais à trois choses passées et cesser
ses investissements ses déficits ont été
faits pour faire croître l'économie
comme vous le savez ça a fonctionné
de rencontres en quatre ans nous avons
eu un des taux de croissance les plus
élevés de tous les pays
g7 la dette par rapport à l'économie
commençait aussi est en chute au canada
c'est un niveau parmi les plus faibles
de tous les pays développés nous avons
canada avec l'allemagne la plus belle
cote la plus haute cote de crédit de
tous les pays à développer donc ça va
bien au canada et en raison entre autres
des investissements qu'on ait fait non
seulement dans les shows dans les
infrastructures mais aussi dans les gens
dans la classe moyenne
ceci étant dit il faut rester
fiscalement responsable les gens
certains s'attendent à ce que leur
argent l'argent public soit investi de
manière responsable et c'est une de mes
responsabilités sénat sur et avec mes
collègues que les fonds publics soient
investis na li responsable budget
fédéral de 350 milliards de dollars donc
effectivement on vous demande d'être
bien dit responsable avec ça se dit un
déficit de 27 milliards alors qu'on
n'est pas en récession mais qu'on craint
une récession un ralentissement
économique
jusqu'où on va aller jusqu'où on peut
étirer l'élastique des déficits
budgétaires s'est donné hier un nouveau
responsable que ces choses à ce fonds
dont je parlais dans les détails mais
vous savez comme moi gerald que ce qu'on
appelle la dette par rapport à
l'économie est probablement l'indicateur
le plus utilisé est le plus fiable que
les études d'économie s'utilise pour
valider si les investissements du
gouvernement se font de manière
responsable
au canada ce ratio dette en apport à
l'économie est en chute depuis 2015
il est à peu près deux fois plus faible
que la moyenne des autres pays du g7
trois fois plus faible que les
américains et il est effet il est dans
une trajectoire qui va continuer à
baisser au cours des prochaines années
comprends bien mais est-ce que vous
préparez une récession mais on veut que
si la récession soit aussi capable
d'être résilient sais pas et cette
résilience est plus facile à atteindre
lorsqu'on est en position forte en
termes économiques et en terme d'emplois
il est pas mal plus solide à tomber dans
une récession lorsque le taux de chômage
était un si faible niveau que lorsque
tout chômage est à un niveau très élevé
puis une autre chose aussi c'est que
parfois la meilleure façon d'avoir une
récession c'est de l'anticiper cette
récession c'est de couper dans les
investissements et dans les
investissements est ce qu'on se prépare
à une récession parce que j'avais
l'impression puis c'est sur une campagne
électorale ont fait des promesses là
vous en aviez pour 9 milliards la
première année 27 milliards de déficit
jusqu'à quel point on est prêt pour une
récession va aller à 50 60 70 milliards
de déficit
non on ne prépare pas pour une des
sessions et évidemment on veut tout
faire pour l'éviter si elle se produit
est généralement les récessions se
produisent en raison de facteurs
externes ça peut être en raison de choc
en termes de commerce international ça
peut être la baisse du prix des
ressources naturelles
si une récession se produisait au canada
on serait en meilleure posture
maintenant en 2010 9,2 de l'absorber
cette récession qu'on l'était en 2015 où
on était déjà en récession avec un taux
de chômage plus élevé que celui qu'on a
maintenant en 2015 en 2019 sachant en
passant que tout chômage en 2010 9 n'a
jamais été aussi faible que depuis le
moment où les statistiques sont au
chômage noté ont commencé à être
calculée par celle-ci canada en 1976 bon
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose là à faire
en arrivant dans votre bureau vous est
le quatrième président du conseil du
trésor en 2019
après les fêtes l'an passé avec scott
bryson il est parti madame philpot est
partie madame mary était là pour
compléter la c'est vous alors vous allez
dire quoi vos collègues et à vos troupes
quand vous allez rentrer au conseil du
trésor
je suis là pour les aider et qu'on est
là pour céder à faire croître l'économie
pour faire croître la classe moyenne et
pour lutter contre la pollution les
changements qu'ils n'étaient que ce sont
les trois enjeux les plus importants de
notre société pour ça ça prend un
gouvernement fédéral du solide
ce sont des enjeux qui sont nationaux ça
prend aussi une capacité au fédéral et
je veux jouer un rôle important cet
égard de travailler avec les
gouvernements provinciaux et municipaux
puisque dans une fédération à nouveau on
a intérêt à travailler les uns avec les
autres
monsieur duclos bonne chance
félicitations merci beaucoup merci à
vous asseoir et